Today we're gonna be looking at SCP 343 object class safe
Special containment procedures
SCP 343 resides in a 6.1 by 6 point 1 meter room at minimal security site 17
It should be brought any items at requests and visited by at least one staff member each day
Attempts to add further safety precautions or required clearances are
Unnecessary and impossible due to the nature of a CP 343
Description
SCP 343 is a male seemingly raceless humanoid and appearance with apparent omnipotence
SCP 343 was discovered walking the streets of prague and detained after a member of staff witnessed him disappear from the streets and
reappear on a rooftop
SCP 343 is detained willingly in his chamber as containment has proved impossible
Addendum 343 - one
SCP 343 colloquially named god by the staff here looks like an older man. Although his features are different to each observer
In my first talk with him he claimed to be the creator of the universe
When I asked him to prove this he laughed
Walked through the wall of the chamber and returned seconds later with a hamburger in his hand
When I returned for a second visit the previously bare
cell had been furnished in an upscale Old English style complete with a roaring fireplace and
Seemed many times larger than it did from the exterior
SCP 343 greatly enjoys speaking with people and seems to have a knowledge of all topics
Visiting with SCP 343 has become a daily event for many of the staff here and all employees report feeling
generally happier after visit
attempts to bar staff below level three clearance have proven unsuccessful as
guards assigned to watch the room quit their posts saying
You know he likes company or shrugging when questioned
Since s CB 343 has thus far been harmless all
Staff have been allowed access and somehow they all have time to meet with them for as long as they need
For now I leave this report open as further questioning of SCP 343 is ongoing
dr. Beck
addendum 343 - -
in
Regards to document 343 1a
There are no relevant records available or seemingly in existence and similarly all
records of DOC
Ever working with a CP 343 or dr. Beck are missing and presumed
non-existent
All staff questioned about the document convey ignorance of document 343 - 1a and claimed not to have met dr.
In a related matter
senior officer dr
Beck has requested a hire staff rotation quote to increase morale in worse off sections end quote
This was a very odd request and was the subject of further investigation
Other localised anomalies such as better health greater job satisfaction
And lower fatalities in this section have led to the request being granted
This subject is now closed on orders of all flight
Addendum 343 - three data recovered on
From routine check of doctor
Network drive
Document number 343 - 1a
data lost as of
data expunged
Visitors of SCP 343 are to be questioned as to their intent and converse data lost
Since pertaining to the other SCP are to be put forth data. Lost orders of dr.
Document 343 - 1b
Data lost
Apparently my orders have gone missing
This is the last straw
Dr. Bell data lost all my reports and requests to higher-ups have gone unnoticed I
Will confront SCP 343 tomorrow signed dr.
You